un solo caso de coronavirus ha desatado
de nuevo esta imagen en nueva zelanda
país que ha reportado menos de 3000
casos y de 30 muertes desde el inicio de
la pandemia la primera ministra decretó
este martes el confinamiento nacional
ante la preocupación de que la variante
delta haya entrado en el país para
rastrear y frenar las cadenas de
transmisión el territorio pasa a nivel 4
de alerta lo que implica el cierre de
escuelas y de todos los establecimientos
no esenciales al menos por tres días de
jetblue
la variante del test considerado un
punto de inflexión y lo es lo que
significa que tenemos que actuar rápida
y drásticamente para frenar su expansión
en otros lugares hemos visto lo que
puede pasar si no llegamos al fondo de
la cuestión nueva zelanda como su vecina
australia ha seguido una estricta
política de confinamientos ante la
detección del mínimo brote en la región
de nueva gales del sur se mantienen los
cierres perimetrales ante un aumento de
los contagios su capital sídney registró
este lunes su récord de fallecidos
diarios por kobe 19 7 en un día
y
creemos que los casos van a aumentar
sustancialmente en las próximas semanas
tenemos que protegernos ante eso pero
nuestra principal preocupación debe ser
mantener a la gente fuera de los
hospitales y con vida
en japón a días de que inicien los
paralímpicos los casos de coronavirus
siguen en aumento el archipiélago del
pacífico extendió el estado de
emergencia que afecta a tokio y otras
prefecturas hasta el 12 de septiembre la
variante delta ha expandido los
contagios por todo el mundo de forma
inaudita y ha cambiado la situación de
nuestro país y la amenaza de la variante
delta ha desatado también la aplicación
de dosis de refuerzo de la vacuna en
varios países una política que ha vuelto
a poner sobre la mesa la desigualdad
global en la repartición del fármaco